over the break michael rappaport was a
guest on the wrap-up show marianne from
brooklyn called in
and their feud continued would you like
to hear that robin
absolutely i am unaware of this all
right here we go
all you do is feel about gary why don't
you come prepared like danny cevallos
or laura whitman you're talking about
gabby you
hate the connor john hang up on this
animal
who was on the sliding rapper who was on
this morning show
who was on yesterday's star theology
[Laughter]
well i think it's ridiculous that he's
arguing with you why is he bothering
with you
because he wants airtime you got it
robin see
he's got nothing going on you're 100
correct
marianne and rappaport both accused each
other of being a bully
here is the clip this is what happened
in case you missed it now marianne you
now you got to shut that beak okay you
got to duct tape that squawky beak
and you got to you're going to listen
you're a whack job we know this
uh you bullied bobo and now you're
getting bullied bound
by me when i see your twitter all you do
is bully like rassan said
you bully everybody okay this is what
we're gonna do now this is what we're
gonna do
this is what we're gonna do
all right there it is there is the feud
and
it goes on this is unresolved i don't
know where we're at where we have
marianne
he called me a bat and the bat is equal
to corona
but how is really where's his career
it's nowhere now with corona
so he's picking on me the thing to the
wrap-up show is that
john hein and gary and rason wrap up
what was going on the show
so i was asking him questions what was
going on and he was clueless
the answer is the answer is
[Laughter]
all right there you go
you